well homelessness we see it in lots of
different pockets of the valley but
recently more and more people are
complaining that camps are now popping
up in their neighborhood eight news now
received a complaint from a viewer about
an area near Nellis and Vegas Valley
that viewer says it's gotten so bad that
they call police they called the county
but haven't seen anything done Madison
Kimbrough joins us now live from The
Stonegate Community not too far away
Madison
as you enter this area of Stonegate
you're going to see several homeless
tents especially under Flamingo Arroyo
Trail but take a look over here as you
can see right by someone's property as
you drive back into the neighborhood
homeless encampments have been set up on
people's property neighbors are now
speaking out
you have to kind of be vigilant and
self-aware of what's going on just
because there's a lot of uh homeless
people that you know suffer from mental
illness drug addiction Glenn Diamond
recalls the environment in The Stonegate
community on the east side of town he's
lived there for years but nowadays
doesn't walk anywhere without his wooden
stick I keep this stick you know just as
a little reason why not to bother me
it's used as protection while walking
his dog as he says the neighborhood has
become a Dumping Ground filled with
homeless and their trash he doesn't feel
safe anymore you kind of want to be safe
where you step at too because there's a
lot of broken bottles human feces urine
you know is is very unpleasant and it's
heartbreaking to see people you know
it's down on their luck while Glenn
didn't want to show his face on camera
his fellow neighbor Jennifer Bennett
says she and her husband who just paid
off their home have considered moving
because it's that bad it scares me I
don't even feel safe going outside at my
backyard we're considering moving out of
Sunrise Manor because of it Bennett
recalls a time where a homeless man
jumped over her wall and attempts to
steal her property she's called Metro
Police and County officials but says it
hasn't helped the problem this is an HOA
and I called 2-1-1 I was told they can't
make him leave
okay and it's it's unsafe where you
don't feel safe walking your dog
I reached out to District e County
Commissioner tick Sager Bloom who shared
with me that he will take action once he
receives a complaint also stating that
he will reconvene with the county back
on Monday when offices are back open
reporting live in the East Valley
Madison Kimbrough 8 News Now
all right so Madison also reached out to
The Stonegate property management
company which is Taylor Association
Management but we have not heard back